georges malbrunot et en direct avec nous
sur arte france
bonjour georges malbrunot merci de
répondre à nos questions ce matin
vous évoquez la difficulté de parler de
la laïcité de défendre le modèle
français dans le monde arabo musulman
opération communication d'emmanuel
maquereau ou véritable main tendue
c'était probablement et 2,7 une
tentative est une nation et b ces propos
qu'il avait tenus le 22 octobre à gauche
mais peut-être lors de l'hommage qui a
été rendu à samuel pâtit ce professeur
assassiné à conflans sainte honorine
lors de cet hommage la sorbonne emmanuel
macron avait dit nous ne renoncerons pas
aux caricatures et il n'avait pas dit
nombreux noms seront pas aux caricatures
du prophète mahomet simplement aux
caricatures le monde arabo musulman
avait compris la france ne renoncerait
pas aux caricatures du prophète et comme
dans le monde arabo musulman la liberté
de la presse
elle n'est pas vraiment une denrée très
courante pour lille beaucoup de
musulmans à travers le monde et bien
lorsqu'il ya eu ensuite des caricatures
qui ont été faites par charlie hebdo sur
sur contre le président turc paient près
de celle d'erdogan
beaucoup de personnes dans le monde
musulman on pensait que ces caricatures
elle était faite à l'instigation du
président de la république emmanuel
macron c'est la raison pour laquelle
hier dans son intervention sur al
jazeera dont vous avez montré des
extraits et bien emmanuel ma croix a
pris soin à la fois d'apaiser les choses
et de dire qu'il pouvait être qui
comprenait que les musulmans soient
choqués par ces caricatures mais surtout
il a dit que lui n'était pas derrière
ces caricatures que ne les approuve est
pas forcément donc il a cherché à se
désengager quelque sorte de toute
responsabilité qui n'a pas d'ailleurs
dans la publication de ces caricatures
mais les agents ça veut dire que vous
vous vous attendez que le chef de l'état
défendent ouvertement charlie hebdo
non
je n'attends rien je pense que emmanuel
macron il à vis de l'extérieur a compris
qu'il fallait apaiser les choses parce
qu'il y avait encore une fois une une
incompréhension qui s'était développée
et qui à partir de cette incompréhension
du 22 octobre sur nous ne renoncerons
pas aux caricatures avait entraîné des
manifestations importantes et de plus en
plus important des lans qu'il y avait
urgence à calmer le jeu une urgence a
rappelé que la france n'était pas un
pays hostile à l'islam qu'il y avait de
nombreux musulmans en france et qui
vivait tout à fait bien qu'il faut pas
tomber dans le piège qui nous est tombé
par certains qui instrumentalisent
effectivement un certain nombre de
propos qui sont tenus ici en france donc
il ya vraiment cette volonté de calmer
les choses parce que la fronde le
sentiment anti français d'en bas 32 pays
et a monté les diplomates français sur
le terrain le constat qu'on fait
remonter ces informations
il pouvait y avoir des mises en danger
d'intérêts français mise en danger
les français eux mêmes donc il y avait
une urgence à dire ce qu'a dit
véritablement désamorcer tout ceci quid
du timing de cette interview emmanuel
macron n'aurait-il pas pu anticiper ces
réactions chez les pays alliés de la
france comme par exemple le liban ou
l'arabie saoudite
je pense que le mal est fait il faut pas
se leurrer les propos d' emmanuel macron
devons pas être oubliés les premiers du
22 octobre comme ça donc le mal est fait
simplement
c'était une première étape indispensable
ensuite la diplomatie française doit
faire passer des messages dans le monde
arabo musulman pour rappeler ce que je
vous disais sky est ce qu a dit emmanuel
macron hier pour expliquer aussi la
laïcité me dit c'est très compliqué mais
surtout pour dire que la france n'est
pas du tout mais pas du tout contre et
du helmand et tu pourras appelé aussi
même qu'il ya eu des violences
absolument inacceptable des assassinats
inacceptable quand tu lui en france donc
c'est une première étape
c'était indispensable il l'a bien fait
sur al jazeera qui est la chaîne du
qatar
ils ont pensé qu'il soutient l'islam
politique est donc ce sont beaucoup de
gens qui regardent à jazeera ne pensent
pas comme nous
et donc il s'est adressé à ce juste
qu'ils pensent pas comme nous et qu'il
cherchait à convaincre de sa bonne foi
et puis le fait que la france encore une
fois n'est pas hostile à l'islam
abu côté on aperçoit accepta hyper
douanes le président turc
emmanuel macron a aussi abordé à les
tensions diplomatiques avec ankara
septe tahi que ratchet tayyip erdogan
respecte la france les modes emmanuel
macron que le président tueur plus
précisément respecte la france est ce
que vous croyez qu'ils emmanuel macron a
été entendu à ce sujet du côté d'ankara
je sais pas s'il a été entendu je pense
qu' il faudra encore plus de deux
déclarations une mesure d'apaisement ce
que j'ai noté c'est que la france
justement dans le cas de volonté
d'apaiser les choses aussi de faire
tomber la tension avec avec la turquie a
décidé de renvoyer son ambassadeur qui
avait été rappelé pour consultations à
paris donc ça veut dire que justement on
veut recréer des liens on veut renouer
avec ankara et qu'il y a aussi nécessité
de de faire retomber la tension
l'escaladé verbale entre les deux pays
simplement il faut que je crois que les
mots ne suffisent pas évoquer les
actions qu'ils soient prises par papa la
turquie notamment notamment en
méditerranée orientale
vous avez rappelé sur votre compte
twitter que la démarche de la présidence
française a été similaire à celle de
pourquoi ce parallèle non c'était pour
dire que y avait une vue
d'incompréhension en 2004 la loi sur le
le l'interdiction du port du voile à
l'école avait été adoptée par le
parlement
elle s'était accompagnée justement dans
les pays arabo-musulmans d'une
incompréhension à ce que parce qu'on ne
comprend pas dans le monde arabe où dans
le monde musulman que une jeune fille ne
puisse pas porter le voile à l'école et
donc il y avait une
nécessité d'expliquer ça et nous qui
avons un pilotage ensuite en septembre
2004 nos ravisseurs vous avez clermont
dit mais pourquoi une jeune fille ne
peut pas porter le voile à l'école
est ce que les musulmans musulmans
français sont persécutés et c'est donc
il y avait eu un souci d'expliquer la
position de la france ce qui avait fait
le bénisse affaires étrangères de
l'époque michel barnier lorsqu'il était
est allé s'exprimer
déjà sur al jazeera pour affirmer que la
france n'était pas contre les musulmans
il y avait délégation d'ailleurs deux
représentants du culte musulman qui
s'était rendu à bagdad donc oui je pense
quitte on a un problème d'accueil à une
incompréhension fondamentale entre la
france laïcité et le monde musulman
je crois qu'il faut pas se le cacher il
faut en être conscient
et à partir de là il faut essayer de
bien essayé de l'expliquer du mieux
qu'on peut et d'éviter les malentendus
qui peuvent déboucher sur thur et
l'aspect terroriste trop souvent hélas
du terrorisme merci georges malbrunot
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes grand reporter au
figaro spécialiste du moyen-orient